The stock market is not the economy.
Many people own no stocks at all.
Many people own very little.
But the stock market is one indicator that
we look at.
And the stock market has collapsed this week
as corona virus continues to explode and ravage
the country.
And as Donald Trump still has no plan nor
even any interest in dealing with the virus
at this point either we keep falling more
and more into a dystopian nightmare with the
pandemic or Donald Trump gets replaced.
It's one of the two.
Trump is not going to fix this.
All right.
But the stock market is absolutely imploding.
The first three days this week, the Dow closing
last week at roughly twenty eight thousand
three hundred.
Monday down 600 points, Tuesday, down another
couple hundred points yesterday, falling off
a cliff.
Down nearly a thousand points.
The decline for these first three days of
the week, about seventeen hundred points.
Now, the specifics of the impact of the stock
market being down are heavily concentrated
among companies and rich people who own the
vast majority of stock.
That is very true.
But this is a signal about the confidence
in the American economy.
And because of the virus, confidence is very
low.
We are seeing record corona virus numbers.
We have a third spike already reaching and
surpassing the single day case highs of late
July.
We've had over 80000 cases multiple days over
the last few weeks of over the last week,
rather.
And even though Trump said we would not see
more deaths, the seven day average of deaths
in the United States has been starting to
climb since the middle of October.
Remember, deaths used to lag cases by two
to three weeks.
Now that we're better at treating the virus
deaths, lag cases by a little bit more.
Even people who die are staying alive a little
bit longer as a sort of moross, that is.
And hospitalizations are peaking again and
potentially on their way to the highest peak
we've seen thus far.
If and when the hospitals get full, you will
see the death rate grow up, doormat go up
dramatically.
And we still have no plan.
The stock market is rattled because there
is still no plan.
Trump bemoaning that the media is talking
about the pandemic, saying at his rallies
and tweeting many times some version of this
tweet from yesterday where he said, quote,
Koven Covered, covered is the unified chant
of the fake news lame stream media.
They will talk about nothing else until November
4th, when the election will be hopefully over.
Then they talk then.
Then the talk will be how low the death rate
is.
Plenty of hospital rooms and many tests of
young people.
He's living in a fantasy world.
And we knew they were going to go with the
idea of let people get used to a thousand
deaths a day.
Let it become normal.
And while that is completely immoral, it actually
might have worked were it only for the deaths.
But this is a real economics lesson, which
Anthony Scaramouch pointed out on Twitter.
And then he Scaramouch, a former guest on
this program.
Check out that interview.
Former White House comms director Scaramouch
tweeted economics lesson for the soon to be
ex president.
The virus needed to be contained to help the
economy and stock markets.
Federal stimulus would never be enough.
You crushed the stock market and the economy
by not understanding this.
Trump thought for political gain.
I will ignore it.
The problem is the economy and the stock market
won't ignore it.
And they will notice that even if they don't
care or agree to ignore the deaths, they are
having a massive impact on the economy.
And as Europe is in its second spike, we're
already in our third and it is getting very
ugly.
We need a plan.
We need someone to take control of the pandemic.
Trump can't do it.
He's also not trying.
They've given up, remember, over the last
weekend.
Trump's deranged Marcellus chief of staff,
Mark Meadows, actually said we're not going
to control the pandemic.
Check this out from CNN.
So here's what we have to do.
We're not going to control the pandemic.
We are going to control the fact that we get
vaccines, therapeutics and other Mitiga.
Why are we going to areas?
Because it is a contagious virus, just like
the flu.
But why not make efforts to contain it?
Well, we are making efforts to contain it
by running all over the country and not wearing
a mask.
Jackson, the vice president, back, back and
forth.
Let me just say, this is what we need to do
is make sure that we have the proper mitigation
factors, whether it's therapies or vaccines
or treatments they've given up.
That's it.
What we have ahead of us, maybe if we replace
Donald Trump with Joe Biden, is that Joe Biden
will take the pandemic seriously.
And in general, American stock markets and
economies do better under Democratic presidents.
That's a historical reality.
And that's also what we're counting on at
this point.
But we have to make it happen.
Otherwise, this this is horrible.
This may only be the beginning.
If we don't remove Donald Trump, let me know
your thoughts and reaction.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.